morning everyone thank you so much for
being here very excited it's my first
buy data both attending and speaking so
very excited thank you to Rebecca who
actually prompted me to come speak here
she will be speaking also at 11:45
so definitely suggest you guys to check
that out it's been a great experience
working in this a great way to dive deep
into a problem and expose it to the
greater community and sorry without
further ado let's get to it so I have
three goals for today first of all
explain some of the problems that arose
when working with machine learning
systems and specifically deploying them
describe some of the solutions that
exist in some of the limitations that
those solutions have and then I'll be
I'll be speaking mostly about the tools
and what you can do with them but also
what what you know a mutations arise you
know more consistently especially when
you're you're you're working and I you
know in a way that you're trying to
build a workflow for doing machine
learning so that you can deploy models
of confidence and lastly I'll be open
sourcing a library which is exciting
I've been working on it for the past
let's say month and right now it's just
closed source and I've been working in
mostly for personal interest and for
some other side projects that use it but
it's closed source and it's gonna be fun
I guess to you know open source it and
present each larger community so I'm
pretty excited about that as well there
we go
some background myself I got my BA my
bachelor's in biomedical engineering and
and bio Mattox mostly dealing with DNA
data and it was it was pretty
interesting and pleased working with
like a fairly large data sets and you
know biomedical engineering usually you
end up learning about of you know many
many things but nothing to death so that
was somewhat painful so I decided to
just be able towards something that I
was interested on and that was software
programming and machine intelligence
machine learning I was lucky enough that
I was working in a lab in which the P is
letting me just big interesting topics
and work work within them so you know I
took like the fine
you know machine learning classes and
you know applied them to some very niche
problems in you know genomic analysis
and that was interesting but you started
learning the pains of doing consistent
you know or repeatable and consistent
workflows with with a machine learning
and sometimes you know dealing with like
you know just strangling like Jupiter
new books and so forth and so that's
that's something that since the
beginning was kind of hard to deal with
so how you manage the workflow of doing
machine learning in general and
currently I'm working at bike you mostly
with in machine machine machine learning
engineering officially I did a scientist
mostly what I do is actually putting
models into production and making sure
that they get to the clients hands in
fact some of the work is even front-end
work and you know the whole goal is just
making sure that whatever models that
are produced doing the analysis phase
they actually get into their clients
hands so there's a lot there's there's a
lot of you know just ensuring that you
know the whole process of doing analysis
actually gets into production in the
proper way and that's most of my focus
and even you know not not just in
research but also now here working in
the industry with clients you realize
that the actual pain of you know putting
out a consistent workflow that lets you
deploy models consistently is a fairly
big pain or at least there is there are
some limitations there that you know are
somewhat hard to overcome and you need
some proper tooling to for you to be
able to manage the whole workflow so big
ways from you know this this whole time
that I have been working both you know
in somewhat in industry and research has
been that you need those key features
whenever you're developing workflows
just one second sorry so you need
repeatable workflows you need something
that is fast that enables you to do fast
iteration and the 80/20 rule that I like
to call here which is basically usually
80% of the your results will come for
from this is working by the way yeah
yeah from 20% of the of the work that
you do in the sense that usually a very
simple model
such as like I don't know gradient
boosting for whoever has done tackle
challenge and so forth
we'll get you most of the results and
delivering those results quickly usually
is something that matters a lot
especially when you have you know
clients asking for results as soon as
possible and I know that this sounds
almost like a pitch for agile but it's
not trust me and I just want to make the
point that you know you want to deliver
those values as quickly as possible so
having good workflows especially for
data science and machine learning helps
a lot and helps you know team deliver
value as quickly as possible so this is
a quote and a the quote itself I don't I
don't mean to diminish any question
learning expert with with these quotes
but the goal you know the this was
actually taken from the Google machine
learning suggestions for or basically
the best practice for machine learning
and basically states that you know some
products they for some products you know
you don't you don't need to focus on the
very needy greedy details of the machine
learning aspects but more so you just
need to focus on delivering a product
that is actually workable so focusing on
the engineering first and then the
actual product itself first should be
one of the goals because you want to
deliver those values as quickly as
possible and one of the things that I've
been focused on at least doing my work
have I cubed and also before hands was
actually providing you know those those
tools so that the data sign science
thing can benefit and you know just have
a large impact within the larger
organization so let's actually get to
the core of the presentation so being
very interested in tens or hundreds of
whole serving in the entire ecosystem
that tends to fall has created around it
mostly because it's it's a it's a pre
interesting library and you know for
whoever has used it is that it's it has
a lot of hidden complexities it's and
sometimes it's hard to reason about it
but there's also you know you know
usually I think most of the usages and
examples that you see of tensorflow are
mostly on the training side and how do
you do specific models or how implement
them in
and not much of it has been focusing on
how you actually deploy it and you make
it available for other people to be used
tensor fault serving is Google solution
for how how to deploy a model in an
efficient scalable manner basically
comes with high performance inference
engine and basically what it does is
keeps the model loaded in memory so that
you don't need to reload the entire
graph basically when doing frames and
you know tends to flow
who has use here it tensorflow people
what about things are full serving okay
yeah so it's much less popular but you
know just it's it's it's also a fairly
recent addition to I guess the tensor
for ICO system but it's it's it's
interesting to a wall you know
tensorflow
most people have used it but basically
what it does what it is is just
scientific computing library that
basically defines graph of computation
through which your data flow so that
it's a data flow computational modeling
tool if anything and something that is
very computationally expensive it is
expensive in general is loading all your
variables and loading all your graph
into memory and that's something that if
you want to do in fear ins you need to
do if you have a model serialize as a
particle buffer or whatever a
serialization format you need to be
reloaded in memory and after that you
can use it but you know one of the cool
things about tensor flow serving is that
that comes out of the box for you and
the model is kept loaded so that the
interference is done quickly and you
don't need to wait for the reloading um
it also has some other interesting
features such as ER PC interface and a
rest interface I'm not gonna go into the
details of the differences of both but
Jerry PC usually allows for faster
inference low latency faster
interference and it also has some
notions of model discovery in that if
you have directories where your models
are stored within the tensor flow
intensive or can access them then if a
new version comes out that is if a new
model gets loaded into one of the
directories the tensorflow serving has
access to you then that model gets
loaded automat
so it's ready for experience so it's
interesting it's not as flexible as you
want because the versioning that they
use is just basically just integers so
you have a directory number one number
two number three and then the latest is
always getting loaded so it's it's
interesting but not too flexible some
details about how they achieve the high
performance interference and you know
the gr PC interface and and so forth I
mean basically as I mentioned it keeps
the mode a lot of model loaded into the
memory so that you don't need to reload
it and reload all the variables so
that's great
and it also has a pretty extensive C++
API which I would label it where as a
limitation that a feature it's pretty
extensive in that you can control the
very like guts of it and how the models
get loaded and you can create your own
version policy as to how the models get
loaded which is pretty cool
you can define also and a few other
things like what kind of inputs the the
model will receive and what kind of
transformations you can do before before
the predictions actually happen so you
have a lot of control into into how the
texture for serving will behave with the
C++ API but you know something that I
mentioned before is that you know when
we're trying to build tools the goal is
reducing the trician between whatever
data science is doing whatever the you
know the developed where at least MVP
product looks like so you know requiring
you know data scientist or whatever to
use a supposed plus API seems to be a
little bit of an overhead at least you
know right now and it's interesting that
they do have a Python API but it's
there's no documentation whatsoever
there's some snippets that you can find
here and there and that's somewhat odd
maybe you know the it's a fairly new
tool so I suppose the documentation is
still catching up but it's it's it's
interesting to see that they have a
Python library just recently they just
released one with a Python 3 support it
was only a 2.7 so also interesting but
yeah undocumented so there's some
limitations there
um and they actually only had a Geo PC
interface until August and it was
interesting because my talk was supposed
to be just about how do you implement
some rest interface in front in front of
10 3 4 serving how you basically make
you know the rest interface talk to your
PC in the interface and that was gonna
be interesting but then ever since they
released the rest interface it didn't
make much sense for me to just talk
about that so I just decided to create
something that went a little bit beyond
so it was interesting I guess but for
sure that having a rest interface makes
it easier for people to just use the
tool and develop tools around the tool
and that's because I mean in general I
want to say that 95 percent of
organizations in yet they use JSON over
HTTP protocol which is you know the
common common standard way that you know
you do requests nowadays um so out of
those limitations my idea was let's
create something that has some nicer
properties or something that at least
it's a little bit smoother to the user
as far as like how you manage models how
you interface with them how you deploy
them and how you query them even and so
forth so that was something that I
thought it would be interesting to work
on and interesting to have a new look at
or at least a new take on and what
resulted from it was you know a library
that I'll be explaining to to you later
but um in general all I wanted to do is
just having something pythonic
documented with a nice clean interface
that lets you track models but also
serve them and also just have easy
access to and you know in the end also
someone will be consuming this model it
might be not yourself you might be some
other developer that needs to get
predictions for you know front-end or
what have you so the idea of having a
clear interface and a clean way of
looking at them is always is always
something that should strive for when
developing you know software products so
before going to the library I just
wanted to take a quick look at
what exist today and some of the tools
that some of you may know and may have
used those are there are some great
tools here clipper that AI is actually
developed by the rise lab at Berkeley
it's a great tool they actually have
many many cool repositories in within
high performance computing unfortunately
it hasn't been much active at least in
size since the last time I checked so
it's it's interesting because it
supports many different machine learning
libraries and you can load models and
its high performance C++ engine that
does the predictions for you as well so
it's it's an interesting tool also works
with containers so you have also that
easy ease of use if anything and then
you have some other platform of the
services type of type of tools like
algorithm and recognition from Amazon
and many other ones and those are
interesting of course if you want to
have you know that full support from
like you know an entire platform of
course we have the issues of underlaw
cane and you know being closed source
and so forth but those are great tools
as well and m/l flow which is by data
bricks
it's a also great tool if you want to do
experimentation of you know new models
and you want to track the model
performance over time not so much for
proper serving because actually at least
as far as tensorflow goes they do
support it but if you want to deploy
something with a melt flow you'll have
to and you want to get a prediction from
you know your deployed model they
basically do the whole like let's reload
the model and tomorrow let's get a grab
all the variables and all this realized
data and reload it and then doing
figurines so you're definitely gonna pay
a performance penalty there but I
definitely recommend people check out
their their their their project because
it lets you quite easily switch between
you know PI torch life you learn you
know extra boost and you know all the
possible libraries and basically try
them out and track the performance over
time and have some nice visualizations
as to how they work so it's a great tool
but maybe not something that you know
fits the idea of having some nice
performance properties and then there's
always because
Solutions you can find them on github
there's many some of you know better or
lower quality but you know custom
solutions exist
that's usually what ends up when you
have a problem a bottleneck I guess is
you just create a custom solution maybe
open source it maybe you don't but
there's always gonna be some of them so
one I wanna introduce to you is you
wouldn't say a framework but it's a it's
a guess an opinionated way of deploying
models using tensorflow serving and it's
basically a pretty minimalistic model
deployment tool that lets you get access
to most of the students for certain
functionality but we find a cleaner
interface well-documented and I
technically easier to use as well and
you know something that takes away most
of the complexities and make sure that
you have some nice properties when
you're doing your you know machine
learning workflow that you know
encompass being able to version your
models or being able to track the
performance over time for being able to
you know visualize that performance over
time so you have some things that have
been at least in my experience somewhat
of a pain to work with and you know have
not been sold by some of the current
solutions so I wanted to put together
something that would have you know a
take on it that you know would hopefully
add something to the discussion so the
motivation basically as I mentioned
before I just wanted to have something
that would let me automate my workflow
and let me you know get to some MVP you
know quicker or get me to something
that's working within you know maybe a
few minutes at most and that you know
goes back to the notion that within an
organization I mean that you need to
develop a product for some client you
just need to get to something working as
quickly as possible so that you can get
that feedback and make sure that you're
always improving moving forward
something also that I thought it was
useful what would be very appropriate to
have would be the ability to exploit the
explore the models that you have access
to you and basically have an idea as to
how their performance has been from the
past until what you have today and you
can track it and query it and manage and
store it in a way that allows you to
basically have access to that model
metadata moving forward
and lastly flexibility I think it's
important you know we don't want to or
at least ideally the tool shouldn't lock
in the user into something that requires
you to go through hoops to change a
single you know configuration and you
shouldn't you shouldn't make the user
change the entire workflow when
developing you know a model for example
and shouldn't have to you know just
change 20 different configuration files
when you know trying to deploy something
so it should be something
straightforward that doesn't change the
data scientists didn't scientist
workflow but allows you to have some
nice properties as far as managing the
stuff that you that you develop and and
and the models that you produce so of
course wouldn't be a data science stuff
without some mention to version control
or some some meme about it but basically
one of the features that I did again
that I wanted to make sure that it was
there and it worked in a nice way would
be the ability to have something that
automates the versioning of your models
and make sure that you know whenever you
have whenever you want to look at the
history of the models that you have
trained you can take a look at you know
the versions of them and their
performance and also basically how they
compare against each other and so that
you can basically select the version
that performs the best for instance or
you can you know cycle through models
that have you know similar performance
with different crafts or characteristics
so you know something something that
that's something that at least in my
experience you know has been like hard
to deal with you know especially when I
don't know whenever you're working with
like you learned for example I need to
take all a model it's
you pickle it and/or you store it
serialize it in whatever format and it's
hard to keep track of which one did what
or which model you know performed how
because I mean all you have access to is
just the name of the file in the end or
maybe some directory in which you store
this so that was something that I felt
it was afraid of limiting or at least
was somewhat just hard to work around
you know and whenever you're doing that
multiple multiple times it becomes a
little bit painful for you to keep track
of that and that's the same for I mean
whatever live were you working with
sometimes doing the proper versioning
takes some extra effort something else
that I wanted to make sure is that I
mean think the name of the talk has
flask in the in the in the in the name
but I haven't mentioned it too much but
one of the goals was also having a
friendly interface for other basically
you know if you were to deploy a model
you need you need to you need it to be
easy to use by others so something that
I wanted to make sure is that whenever
you serve a model you have also nice
interface that's self documenting and
and allows people to just query it using
the most common types of you know tools
like curl or whatever requests library
that you're using so that you have
access to that you know you know in a
nice way so the basically the library
itself has built in a way of creating a
server that lets you access the model
and he uses flask and flask restless
which is a basically any you know API
building library and that comes with
swagger documentation out of the box
which is also great always makes it
easier to develop things and share
things with other people other things
that I wanted to have since the
beginning was a nice expressive CLI just
because I think you know having being
able to have access to most of the
functionality you know through a few
commands would be easy would be would be
great or at least like would make sense
for you know the common user that once
you have access to you know most of the
functionality with very few keystrokes
and also static typing because Python 3
six and thirty seven are great and you
know optional typing features from you
know developed with my PI and so forth
or pretty awesome and usually help with
like having code that documents itself
and having people whenever they look at
your code they they will get a better
glimpse of what the code is doing if you
have the types there and it's mixi makes
the developer experience much easier so
also definitely recommend that for
people so this whole talk I guess has
been mostly yes or at least the idea has
been like developing this way of like
having a way of doing machine learning
that it's more understandable or at
least more clear not only to the to the
people with person who's developing the
models but also the person who is
interfacing with them so you know I see
to two personas here that you know the
library should target and one of them is
data scientist or the machine learning /
- practitioner that is actually
developing them but also other software
engineers other developers that will be
using the results of the model into
either some you know front-end or some
other place that requires the outputs of
a machine learning model so from the
developers perspective we want to have
something that's easy to integrate easy
to deploy so something that I focus on
also was getting docker to work out of
the box or at least having dr. as you
know starting point from anything you'd
be deploying and that's usually a very
nice way to make sure that workflows are
reproducible and whatever you're running
will run in other places so the docker
plus you know the restful axis were
think that you know makes you usually
make the developer experience at least a
little bit more enjoyable and visibility
also being able to know what are the
inputs for the model and being able to
basically query an endpoint and know
what the data should be should be for
that specific model is also useful
because sometimes you don't want to deal
with like issues with your
you know Empire raise sizes or shapes or
whatever usually those are eyes pretty
pretty commonly and then from the other
perspective oh here I have a simple code
of how you would define a model using
the library which is interesting I mean
I think it's pretty standard but
basically you just inherit from a class
that has some you know some some methods
that will allow you to store the model
and automatically push it into the
tensor flow serving library so that it's
already serving but basically you know
the goal here is just having a workflow
that doesn't put any code that doesn't
put any major constraint on data
scientists and lets you develop you say
the workflow the way you used to do it
before but it gives you extra
functionality that you can use if you if
you wish to so you know the build model
method is just you know a classic Kerris
sequential model that you know defines
the field a few layers and returns the
compiled model although they're all said
that there is well in this class is just
the definition of a version name and a
model type and a call to store method
which basically does all the things that
I mentioned that is storing the model in
the perfect format putting into
tensorflow and serving it automatically
I'm gonna give a quick demo later or
actually at the end of the talk so you
can see how you would use this and how
you go from this to something that's
serving a machine learning model in like
a minute and a half so you'll see more
or less but again the I guess the point
I guess or the larger idea here is that
if you want to develop some workflow for
doing machine learning we want to make
sure that we don't put any barriers to
data scientist and we don't mess up the
workflow or at least don't put any
constraints and make sure that it stays
as consistent as it was before and you
know whether we be in a Jupiter notebook
or and some like Python file this at
least doesn't doesn't at least my
experience you shouldn't you know add
any constraint or any difficulties as
far as like how you do the machine
learning but it gives you some added
benefits as far as how you serialized
version of your models and so forth
[Music]
so actually oh the demo is actually
right now so uh I'll just show a quick
recording off a of my screen while it's
gonna be maybe a little bit too small
it's if you can zoom in so uh first of
all this is s Kinema which is a great
tool also hidden Python for recording
terminals I'll recommend if you if you
ever need to give a damn or you know
showcase something it's a great tool but
in any case so I'm just gonna say that
this is a clean environment with just
the library installed and nothing else
an empty directory and I'm just going to
type some commands and get to in the end
to a model that's been certain in within
ten circles serving with those nice
properties and and walls that's pretty
much it
so um just quick now something that I
that I like doing is just having
whenever developing a project someone
will use have a way to just you know not
have to start from zero but start from
like some point in which you already can
get to something that works with the
least amount of time so that first
command basically generates the
scaffolding that you need and all the
doctor files and configuration files
that you need to deploy your first model
with not much attrition so that should
you know that you know that in it just
creates that the directory creates the
scaffolding and you have access to all
those the doctor files and the doctor
compost files doctor file contains the
definition of the tensor for serving so
it's actually taking pretty much
straight from the tense before serving
library with some modifications to make
your work with the project but that's
pretty much it and then some started
files like this one and this one are
just like the sample files that I showed
you pretty much on the pure slide so you
have access to do is just so that I can
use that you can start playing with it
so this is the file that I showed before
doctor compose file nothing nothing
crazy here then we're gonna run the
doctor compose command to start off
start off the start off the container of
course we'll take some some more time to
build it if it's you know if you haven't
downloaded it's a pretty large image
actually but you know once you do it
once that you're good to go
of course that was like for at books to
think or talk stuff like very small in
your network so that was very quick but
we can imagine that might think as long
as needed but so once you run the model
and you call that store method then it's
already loaded into tensorflow serving
and it's already ready to make
predictions and you can do some other
clearing of the models and see what
exists that's like one of the CLI
commands lets you you know take take a
look at that you can query the active
model
okay
right and then to actually start off the
API server that lets you actually you
know do requests to the model you need
to started there's a specific command
but that will basically stand up the
flash server with the API and so forth
and starting in the background so we can
clear up the well we can now test it
just send a simple curl request and you
get your predictions back pretty fast
and you know it basically that queries
flash queries sensor for serving get
through predictions back so there you go
that's pretty much it and I guess they
made a meter and a half you can get to a
nice model running production this is
actually on the oops go back over is it
yeah the dogs have some more information
about it I tried making them extensive
and here's the project still haven't
then much I mean or at least heaven it's
still actually private so what I wanted
to do today as I mentioned the beginning
open source a library so that's exactly
what I'm gonna do you know again I've
been working on this for the past like
maybe a month and a half two months and
it's been pretty exciting but I wanted
to make sure that other people can have
a starting point again this is not a
bulletproof solution by any standard but
it's a way that maybe will give people
an idea of like how you can create a
workflow that's or something that
creates a workflow that lasts you you
know have access to some set of tools
that I found to be interesting at least
in my my time doing machine learning and
you know the point model so you know
that model versioning model you know
serializing them automatically and so
forth so those are the things that
hopefully someone will get some some you
know maybe some useful snippets or some
code that might be interesting so make
it public Oh haven't done this before so
don't you know oh
damnit nice cool and that's pretty much
it actually I do have a slide with flag
that talks about the moving forward but
I guess you can find that in the
documentation as well as far as like
what's missing in the library so I'll
just open it up for questions now thank
you great talk
now that racket is open-source what are
some of the things you would like
potential contributors to consider
contributing what is missing from your
perspective that that we should think
about sure well first of all it's
something that I've you know used
sparingly here in there and mostly
developed in a way that it could be used
by others but at the same time I haven't
used it extensively enough to know what
bottlenecks are and when it fails
um so testing is one thing and it has a
decent coverage but many edge cases I
only catch them when I'm actually typing
the commands and seeing that it goes
wrong so testing is one thing second
would be let's see maybe some some
explanation of some workflow that would
take you that to some actual deployed
version on some of the major cloud
providers for example having a
kubernetes example the appointment or
maybe WI CCS or what have you so those
things that are you know things that I
didn't take too much time just because I
guess I mean time constraints but those
things that would be interesting for
people actually using it and actually
deploy models would be great and testing
always
I have two questions one on our the
metric stored in the SQLite database
yeah actually so thanks for mentioning
that usually you can specify on that
there's a racket diamo file that gets
generated once we initialize the library
and you can specify the connection
string to your database I use sequel
Lite and if you specify a Postgres
connection then you can use that for
example but the idea is just having you
know I use you know psycho alchemy and
psycho alchemy basically as the ORM to
store the data but yes it's all store in
spotlight database and when you send the
model to the doctor the tense of serving
API with the COI
how is the data transferred like great
question it's actually through doctor
volumes so you specify the volume off
your fat off you're basically a
directory inside the project that's
actually get created it gets created
automatically and then you specify that
volume to be inside some model that gets
mad at some some directory that gets
mapped inside the docker container and
so you get that nice sharing so you
don't need to copy data at all is just
there so but actually that's a good
point as far as like what if you want to
deploy it sometimes the doctor volume
and there's a not I'm kind of hazy on
that but sometimes if you want to deploy
something there and you have the data in
the volume you need to freeze it or at
least me to actually copy it there if
you want to for example push the doctor
file to some repositories so that's
that's that's a good point out and I'll
keep that in mind yeah
[Music]
hi no this is a super awesome project
I'm definitely gonna use it a question
that I have I'm not familiar with TF
serving but I assume that it's really
good at getting the getting like the
inference to run as fast as possible but
once you have like your flask server and
you're trying to intake in a lot of
requests as well as data that you know
is just huge like an image like what
would be good kind of tools or good or
like how can you be [ __ ] your flask
server once it's now kind of served like
with like 10 full serving that's
actually a great question and something
that I've thought about myself the flask
you know the idea is just having like an
API that it's well known to people and
you know you have this nice you know
swagger documentation and all that but
something that I've been thinking about
is just using the tensor for serving you
know semantics that are built in like
using the G RPC interface which allows
for you know big directional streaming
and you know just much faster access and
they use protocol buffers as a as a
serialization instead of JSON which is
you know much much more efficient so
something that I thought about was like
what about and haven't implemented it
this yet something that I thought about
was what if we you know have the flask
to basically document the actual G RPC
interface so that people when using they
can choose between using the GPC
interface or using the flask if they
just want to use the simple JSON you
know so we can have both so then to ask
also something else I guess if I was
kind of more interested in this should I
look more into the GRP see in like two
tensorflow serving to figure out how to
best handle all this incoming data or
are there just better kind of other kind
of libraries for for these kind of
incoming requests
that's if your if your bottleneck is
influence performance and that's
actually like the reason why Google
really is the teepee use was actually
just just bottlenecks when experience
then you should definitely look into the
jvc and the actual you know the you know
barest metal type of like solutions
which are usually the jerk PC ones and
that you know will boil down to you know
the C++ experience engine that they have
so flask I guess yeah you can maybe
something that I still need to do
actually wasn't the steel that needs to
be done is the batching of requests so
that you know batching usually performs
better than one offs so having a way of
doing that but you know you can you can
give flasks maybe you know some a better
performer and you know whiskey server
that would make it maybe it maybe help
but you still have a bottleneck with the
Jer PC usually you have better
characteristics it implements a better
HTTP protocol so I would look into that
if that's your bottleneck and that maybe
distribution as far as like you know
distributing load across many servers
and so forth but and even usually you
using TP use at that point but yes flask
will be your bottleneck in case you're
trying to like push it too much yeah how
about security is there anything else we
should be thinking about special was
secured here that's it's a great
question that's that's something that I
haven't really thinking a look at too
much but or at least I haven't like
given it enough thoughts but I mean you
know since you know since if you're
gonna really be exposing the endpoints
you know you should definitely have at
least some sort of like some some
security practice in place of course and
whether it be you know just TLS
encryption or maybe getting access to
tokens that's something that I just I
guess who have been working on something
related to it but not within the context
of machine learning so you know security
I guess it's usually better left to the
experts but I agree that something
that's definitely lacking and
contributors if someone with you take a
look at how to implement something that
will help making the endpoint secure in
in some way
I'll be more than happy to you know take
a look at that and as you mentioned I
guess you know it's a big issue and
luckily enough flask has a lot of
options as far as like plugins for
security but I haven't I haven't think I
look too much into those but thank you
maybe time for one more question
anyone else all right thank you
so give a round of applause to Carlo
[Applause]